lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
practicar algunos ejemplos de ejercicios
de khan academy que tratan sobre
reflexión de funciones el primero dice
esta es la gráfica de la función f
entendido la función que está definida
como que de x es igual a efe de menos x
también entendido cuál es la gráfica de
g en el sitio web de can academy hay una
opción múltiple pero por el bien de este
vídeo creo que será más divertido pensar
en cómo se parece la función g sin tener
opción múltiple solo esbozando la
pausa el vídeo y trata de dibujarla
aunque sea en tu mente bien vamos a
trabajar juntos ya hemos dicho que gtx
es igual a efe de menos x así que cuál
sea el valor de f en un cierto valor de
x esperamos que se obtenga el mismo
valor de f pero en el negativo del valor
de x por ejemplo podemos ver que f de 4
es igual a 2
entonces esperamos que g de -4 sea igual
a 2
una vez más esto pasa porque gt menos 4
es lo mismo que efe del negativo de
menos 4 es decir
efe de 4
así que podemos seguir con esta idea
cuál será el valor de g de -2 bueno será
el mismo valor de f 2 que es igual a 0
así que marcaré este punto cuál será el
valor de g de 0 bueno será el mismo
valor que f de cero porque el negativo
de 0 0 y ft 0 está aquí parece ser menos
2 y ya puedes ver hacia dónde vamos ya
hemos hablado en vídeos previos que si
reemplazas tu x con menos x está
reflejando sobre el eje y entonces que
se va a ver algo así una vez más g de
menos 6 es igual a efe de 6 así que esta
será la gráfica de gea
si estás en khan academy elige la opción
de la gráfica que más se parezca a esta
forma que sea una reflexión sobre el eje
bien hagamos otro ejemplo ahora nos
dicen ésta es la gráfica de la función
fx igual a esto que tenemos aquí cuál es
la gráfica de gd x igual a y tenemos
esto de aquí una vez más pausa el vídeo
e intenta hacer un esposo en tu mente
bien vamos a trabajar juntos esta vez no
han reemplazado a x con menos x en su
lugar gtx es igual al negativo de toda
la función fx podemos escribir kg de x
es igual a observar todo esto es nuestra
definición de ft x por lo tanto gdx es
igual a menos
fd x en lugar de tener efe de menos
x tenemos a menos efe de x por ejemplo
podemos pensar que siempre de cero es
igual a 270 será es negativo de eso será
igual a menos 2 y podemos seguir con
esta idea puedes ver que cualquier valor
de f dado para un cierto valor de x el
valor de g de ese mismo valor será el
negativo del valor de f
así que en este caso estaríamos aquí
así que gtx es una reflexión de fx sobre
el eje x así que se va a ver algo así
una reflexión de efe sobre el eje x y te
encargo que selecciones la opción que se
vea de esta forma en khan academia
bien hagamos otro ejemplo
las funciones efe sólida en color azul y
que punteada en color rojo están
graficadas cuál es la ecuación de que en
términos de f así que pausa el vídeo e
intenta responder la clave es saber cómo
transformamos fx déjame etiquetar la
estás ftx de tal manera que obtengamos
que bueno efe - x es una reflexión de
efe sobre el eje i
es decir intersec a al eje que aquí y
después tenemos en el lado izquierdo una
parte recta de esta forma sólo estoy
experimentando y después sí efe de menos
6 es igual a 6 entonces al poner fm x a
6 obtenemos el mismo valor de 6 así que
efe - x parece algo más o menos así
pero observa que la gráfica morada es
efe - x ahora esto no nos da la función
g pero nos acerca ya que parece que la
reflexión de f
x sobre el eje x nos da la función g
ahora bien como reflejamos algo sobre el
eje x bueno es justo lo que vimos en el
ejercicio pasado multiplicamos la
función completa por un signo negativo
entonces podemos decir que gdx es igual
a menos
efe - x estamos trabajando con dos
reflexiones para obtener g primero
reflejamos sobre el eje y y después
reflejamos sobre el eje x
hagamos un ejemplo más las funciones
efe sólida y que punteada están
graficadas efe está definida como jefe
de x es igual a 4 que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada de 2 - x y después a eso
le restamos 8 cual es la ecuación de g
esta vez no nos piden la ecuación de g
en términos de f quieren saber la
ecuación de fie así que pausa el vídeo y
piénsalo un poco
bueno puedes ver de manera clara que
tenemos una reflexión sobre el eje y
sabemos de manera clara que en una
reflexión sobre el eje y gtx es igual a
efe de menos x como lo sabemos bueno
cualquier valor de f dado para un cierto
valor de x la función g del negativo de
ese valor de x es igual al mismo valor
que la función ftx otra forma de
pensarlo es que si f
8 es igual a algo ligeramente arriba de
4 entonces g de 8 va a ser igual a algo
ligeramente arriba de 4 es igual al
mismo valor entonces cuál es la ecuación
de g bueno tendremos que reescribir esto
para escribirla como una ecuación
entonces podemos decir que ge x es igual
y si reemplazamos todas las x por menos
x en la ecuación que obtenemos
obtenemos 4 que multiplica a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 - y en lugar de x pondré
menos x y por último el menos 8 que está
afuera del radical entonces podemos
decir que quede x es igual a 4 por la
raíz cuadrada de 2 más x menos 8 y hemos
acabado